تبقى معنا فقط لان نذهب الى نجوان سمري
التي تابعت مؤتمرا صحفيا للاجهزه الامنيه
اعود اليك نجوان ما الذي
رصدت نعم بالفعل قبل قليل كان يتحدث
المفتش العام للشرطه وايضا قائد الشرطه في
منطقه
المركز يعني بطبيعه الحال عادوا على
تفاصيل هذه العمليه لكن ربما الاعلان كان
من جانب قائد الشرطه عن انه تم في الدقائق
الاخيره الماضيه القاء القبض على المشتبه
الاخر الذي كانت الشرطه تطارده منذ وقوع
هذه العمليه وتمكنه من الفرار من الموقع
لكن حتى الان لم يتم الاعلان فيما اذا كان
قد شارك في عمليه الدهس لكن تم الاعلان
بانه احد اقرباء لل منفذ ال العمليه وهما
من عائله واحده من بني نعيم في الخليل
ويدور الحديث عن
اقرباء الاول يبلغ من العمر
24 عاما والاخر يبلغ من العمر 44 الذي تم
اعتقاله قبل قليل من قريه بني نعيم في
منطقه ال الخليل والقائد باسم الشرطه
ووفقا ايضا لبيان صدر عنه قبل قليل
الاثنان لا يحملان تصاريح عمل ولا دخول
الى مناطق ايه ال داخل الخط الاخضر في
اسرائيل وحتى انه هناك امر منع اي منع
حصولهم على تصاريح اطلاقا من اجل الدخول
وهذا يعني بان لديهم ربما خلفيه امنيه
وفقا لما تشير له الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وعليه بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي بمشاركه
الشرطه باجراء تحقيقات وفحوصات كيف تمكنا
من الدخول الى اي ال المناطق الاسرائيليه
وعبور كل الحواجز العسكريه
وجدار الفصل العنصري وهناك بطبيعه الحال
في هذه الفتره تحديدا في خضم الحرب
تعزيزات امنيه كبيره جدا للشرطه والجيش
على طول خط التماس بين مناطق الضفه
الغربيه وبين مناطق الداخل الفلسطيني
للحيلوله من عدم دخول اي شخص فلسطيني حتى
من كانوا يملكون تصاريح دخول وعمل منعوا
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب من الدخول الى
اي مناطق الداخل الفلسطيني والمدن
الاسرائيليه حتى العمال الفلسطينيين منعوا
من العوده الى اعمالهم مع بدايه هذه الحرب
لذلك الان اعلنت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بانه بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
بدا تحقيقا كيف تمكن هؤلاء الشخصين
بالمناسبه تم الاعلان في وسائل للاعلام
الاسرائيليه عن اسمائهم لكن يفضل ان نترى
الى حين بطبيعه الحال الاعلان من مصادر
فلسطينيه بان العائله تلقت هذا الخبر اي
عن اسماء الاشخاص الذين ي الذين يتهمان
بتنفيذ هذه ال العمليه لكنهم من قريه بني
نعيم بالقرب من مدينه الخليل وهما اقرباء
وفقا لما نشرته الشرطه الاسرائيليه الاول
يبلغ من العمر 24 عاما و وهو من تم
اعتقاله في موقع العمليه واتهم بتنفيذ
عمليه الطعن والدهس في اكثر من موقع بعدها
بدات الشرطه الاسرائيليه تط مشاركه منحيات
تابعه لشرطه في المؤتمر الذي تحدث فيه
المسؤول
الامني تحدث عن فتح تحقيق فيما يتعلق بكيف
دخلوا الى الى بعد الخط الاخضر لكن في
المعلومات الاوليه نقلا مع القناه ال 14
الاسرائيليه كان هناك حديث بانهما يقيمان
في اسرائيل بشكل غير قانوني تضعين في
السياق نعم تماما وهو ما كنت اتحدث عنه
لذلك لجات الشرطه الاسرائيليه الى الجيش
ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي ل البدء بفحص كيف
تمكن الش الشخصان المتهمان بطبيعه الحال
بالدخول الى المناطق الاسرائيليه من منطقه
الخليل جنوب الضفه الغربيه ونحن نتحدث عن
عدي العديد من الحواجز العسكريه لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على طول خط التماس
بدء من المناطق الشماليه في اقصى شمال
الضفه الغربيه وصولا الى المناطق الجنوبيه
ومحافظه الخليل وحتى المناطق التي تقع الى
الجنوب من مدينه الخليل هناك تعزيزات
كبيره هناك حتى اغلاق لطرق كانت اي كان
يسلكها الفلسطينيون قبل هذه الحرب قام جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باغلاقها بشكل كامل
في مناطق مختلفه تم التضييق على هذه المدن
وعلى هذه البلدات الفلسطينيه ومع ذلك
يتمكن شابان فلسطينيان من الوصول الى
رعنانا الى شمال تل ابيب الى المركز الى
الى المناطق التي تعد وسط اسرائيل ويمكثان
هناك بشكل غير قانوني اي انهم لا يملكان
تصاريح عمل في الوقت الذي حتى من كان يملك
تصاريح دخول الى اسرائيل سواء كان من
المرضى او من العمال او ممن يعملون في
اسرائيل علما بانه بالعاده لا يتم اعطاء
الفلسطينيين تصاريح دخول الى المناطق
الاسرائيليه بشكل تلقائي وانما هي حالات
استثنائيه فقط وحتى هذه الحالات
الاستثنائيه تم منعها مع بدايه الحرب في
في السابع من اكتوبر عبد السلام والغيت
كافه التصاريح للفلسطينيين سواء كان من
العمال من المرضى من اي صاحب شان كان يدخل
الى مدينه القدس من من باقي ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه او الى مناطق اخرى تم منعهم
بالكامل والغاء التصاريح بشكل جارف ومطلق
وهذا كان احد النقاشات في الاجتماعات
الامنيه الاخيره التي عقدت في مجلس الحرب
وفي الكابينه المجلس الوزاري الامني صغر
وعن الخشيه من ان يؤثر
ذلك ويساهم في تاجيج الاوضاع في الضفه
الغربيه تحديدا مع منع العمال ولذلك الان
عندما تظهر هذه التحقيقات الاوليه للشرطه
الاسرائيليه بان منفذي العمليه هما ممن لا
يملكون تصاريح فهذا يثير العديد من
التساؤلات كيف تمكنا من الدخول في خضم هذه
الحرب في خضم تجديدات امنيه غير مسبوقه
على الضفه الغربيه وعلى الطرق وعلى
الحواجز التي تمت مضاعفتها مع بدايه هذه
الحرب سواء كان باقامه مزيد من الحواجز
العسكريه او اغلاق الطرق بشكل كامل يعني
حتى التنقل في الضفه الغربيه من مدينه الى
اخرى او من بلده الى اخرى اصبح شبه مستحيل
واصبح به صعوبات بالغه والان ان يتمكن
هؤلاء من عبور كل هذه الحواجز وكل هذه
التجديدات الامنيه والوصول الى مدينه ضمن
المدن الواقعه في وسط مدينه اسرائيل فهذا
بطبيعه الحال اخفاق كبير للاجهزه الامنيه
لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وللشرطة